it looks inviting but you wouldn't want
to swim in there that is dark and lonely
water it looks toxically blue and it is
it's alkaline it's got a pH above 11 it
would be like swimming in diamond bleach
not enough to cause immediate injury but
enough to irritate your skin and your
eyes overtime enough to cause some
problems a day or so later it would feel
like if you'd washed with soap and then
didn't rinse it off just letting it dry
that alkaline comes from limestone this
is an old limestone quarry leaching
calcite crystals into the water it can't
be drained where would you pump it to
just harm the local water supply then
fill up with rainwater and become toxic
again only a fool would ignore this but
there's one born every minute but for a
while this wasn't the Blue Lagoon this
was the Black Lagoon and the black
wasn't dangerous it was black dye put in
by the local council it was harmless but
that bloom that's inviting the black
with the dye in it was just as toxic it
was just as unhealthy it was just as
likely to make you ill it was just as
likely to give you a nasty fungal
infection a few days later because you'd
accidentally bleached part of your body
but blue water it's tropical seas
sunshine and holidays black water or
darkness when in that dying this water
black was a genius idea it did more than
a hundred warning signs ever could and
it meant that a lot of people didn't end
up getting healed from swimming but now
it's 2015 the blue lagoon is blue again
and I guarantee you this summer someone
is going to bleach themselves
you